if you have multiple universes it turns  out gravity can spill out of one  universe and be felt by another and if  we have another Universe adjacent to  ours it could be that these sites where  we see extra gravity is ordinary gravity  in a parallel universe  and here we are looking at it  mysteriously like what is this it's like  the the blind man touching the elephant  I don't know what this whole thing is  but here I can describe this part of it  and it's kind of textured and it's no no  no this guy it's it's smooth and hard  and you know you can't see the whole  elephant maybe the elephant is ordinary  gravity in Another Universe and we're  feeling it and we're making stuff up  just to account for it